a paris une marche partie du trocadéro a
été lancée sur l'appel du leader des
patriotes florian philippot sur place
nous retrouvons notre envoyé spécial
notre reporter lucas léger
bonjour allik alors quelle est
l'ambiance sur place
eh bien il ya des manifestants un peu
moins que d'habitude il faut dire que le
temps est particulièrement aux mauvais
aujourd'hui il pleut il fait froid vous
pouvez regarder sur ces images de ma
cisma des roses qu'il ya tout de même
des personnes qui ont fait le
déplacement toujours mobilisés alors
qu'olivier ferrand a annoncé jeudi
l'ouverture de la troisième dose à toute
la population de plus de 18 ans il
espère que les personnes qui refusent
cette troisième dose vous rejoindre les
rangs des manifestants mais plus
largement ici on critique toutes ces
mesures sanitaires depuis le début aux
demandes la liberté liberté c'est le
slogan qu'ils passent leur temps à
entonner je vous propose d'écouter
quelques manifestants à qui j'ai pu
parler
mais je suis là parce que le pass
sanitaire c'est une hérésie c'est
antidémocratique
cet ignoble et puis jusqu'à combien de
temps va devoir se prendre là bientôt
faudra voir la perfusion ce sera plus
pratique j'ai 55 ans je fais partie de
la génération où on avait droit de faire
ce qu'on voulait quand vous voulez à qui
on voulait et là je me rends compte que
malheureusement j'ai plus droit de faire
quoi que ce soit avec qui que ce soit ma
famille je peux aller manger au
restaurant avec eux je peux plus aller
voir mon fils qui habite dans le sud
parce que je peux pas prendre le tgv je
peux rien faire en fait et pour moi
c'est pas possible tout simplement quoi
il faut il faut se battre jusqu'au bout
on est on est mal traitée par notre
gouvernement
notre gouvernement s'entête dans des
mesures liberticides a obligé les gens à
se vacciner une troisième fois
présent lui aussi à la manifestation
florian philippot
le chef du parti les patriots il a
pointé du doigt les mensonges du
gouvernement depuis le début de cette
crise ajoute propose de l'écouter
sont des déclarations qui d'abord révèle
le mensonge énorme de ce gouvernement
qui a dit vers en lui-même castex
vaqueront tous dit il y aura pas de
passe à terre puis henri maurin mais pas
étendu au restaurant bio no 1 mais pas
après le 15 novembre mais nos reins mais
la troisième dose ne sera pas intégrée
mensonges mensonges mensonges qu'on peut
pas être gouverné par le manceau avoir
été au bout d'un moment et deuxièmement
c'est la folie totale cette stratégie
est écoutée l'europe est la zone où il
ya le plus de contamination dans le
monde mais on l'a dit lui-même les deux
tiers c'est la zone où il ya le plus le
tout vaccinal où il ya le plus de passes
et un dock c'est un échec radical et
points dans donc on change radicalement
de stratégie et ont rien de ce qui
marche dans le monde ce qui marche
annoncée la liberté c'est pas c'est
d'investir leur hôpital c'est de laisser
traiter les gens c'est pas la folie
actuelle leur pour qui on est debout
mais on sera deux roues jusqu'au bout
lors ces manifestants sont aussi très
inspiré par le mouvement social qu'il ya
eu dans les antilles en martinique et en
guadeloupe le gouvernement a lâché du
lest sur la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants et des pompiers il l'aura
laissé jusqu'au 31 décembre avant de
débuter cette obligation vaccinale
florian philippot s'est félicité sur
twitter de cette réussite on va gagner
tous ensemble c'est ce qui va écrire
merci lucas pour toutes ces précisions